[Music]
I whip my move back in for my place in
it that's it so fun with mommy but if we
move back it will probably turn it back
in for [ __ ] with my weed back before we
mousse it Nick Maxine for you know I
love Nintendo is my friend oh I can't
pretend oh and I've kind of thought
about how to play like we over ps3 in my
360 Microsoft and PlayStation Move it's
time to choose which one is best
let's do a test hell I'm impressed cuz
I'm obsessed
first off Xbox and PlayStation you get
points off with too much calibration and
connect worse fists is an 8 foot so
while blue looks like a Dion ice cream
with my [ __ ] dick back it for fun with
my be back therefore we will connect
back in for my with my move back in for
publican it back in for our commune
while the MOOC issue to swing in all
over the in the face you connect back in
for fun with my we but we will connect
back in football with my move back in
for public in it back in for we will get
there
oh he will connect back in [ __ ] we mu
connect back in for a while short up now
thank you guys so much for watching this
video I hope you're all whipping your
wheeze and your moves and connects at
home but hopefully you put the strap on
so you didn't accidentally slip the
remote out of your hand and have it hit
your television and break it that would
be bad and I in that level tickle my
iPad here he will take you to the
extended director's cut of the video
more dancing from the ladies can't go
wrong with that also there's a special
guest star cameo that's only in my
version and a classic cameo people I'm
talking classic no it's cool check it
out my channel black nerd comedy I got
lots of other video game related music
videos there I'm talking a Super Mario
bromance Street Fighter pho down
Throwdown Konami code reviews and rants
and blogs a plethora of black marinus
every single week thank you so much
Vsauce
you are the awesome sauce that was dumb
please delete that don't put that in the
video